and once again it's time for a 13
o'clock movie retrospective yeah this
was Dagon it's a good one actually it's
funny because as I think I've mentioned
this before on the show but I really
like to choose movies that maybe are
kind of under the radar a little bit so
you know kind of undiscovered gems sort
of thing now this really seems to fit
the bill the interesting thing about
this even though it was directed by
Stuart Gordon who obviously very famous
for doing a reanimate her and from
beyond write classic ones class so this
is one of his later films but I don't
think I ever saw it back in the day no
we only happen to watch it you would
seen it I think yeah it's not a long
time ago it kind of crept up on me I was
like where'd this come from
right this is the same guy that did
reanimate her yes same guy that did from
beyond and I love those movies I was a
kid yeah and this one does not fail to
deliver this is an awesome flick and it
and it is also a Lovecraftian movie yeah
if you're into Lovecraft horror you will
recognize a lot of stuff from this but
the budget is a lot better and the
acting is a lot better than the old
classics even though I love the old
reanimate er and yeah from beyond their
code they're cool flicks but this really
takes it to another level it really does
and and like I said it's weird because
me being into Stuart Gordon to me being
into HP Lovecraft
I think it's unusual that I actually
didn't see this when it came out
yeah it kind of like crept up I don't
know where it really did and you know
the thing is that we actually saw it
because it turned up on to be TV yeah
last reveal my bags you can watch it for
free you can watch it for free it's a
it's still up there to be TV and I guess
it didn't get a theatrical release in
the u.s. it should be said it's actually
a Spanish film even though it was
directed by Stuart Gordon you know
everyone else pretty much everyone else
widget off which is actually perfect for
this story because it's it's set in a
Spanish setting yeah it's like a fishing
village somewhere I guess it's Spain it
is Mori veter it's a Spanish controlled
Island I'm not sure it is Shane okay
yeah and that's where they filmed it so
it did get a theatrical release in Spain
did fairly well there but it didn't get
a theatrical release anywhere else I
don't
and especially not in the US and it
really wasn't it was really Sun here
just went direct-to-dvd like in 2002 or
2003 it's a good flick excellent writing
excellent costumes good acting this
story is is this written very well yeah
and it's a good mixture of practical
effects and early CG yeah I wouldn't say
it was great CG but it is yeah the CG is
not stellar no but it serves but yes
it's not that bad and actually there's
not a lot of it used so you don't really
need it so it's not really like super
noticeable yeah but the cool thing about
this now even though the movie is called
Dagon and HP Lovecraft did publish a
short story in 1919 that was called
Dagon uh who was you know a sea god and
things like that
this movie is actually not so much based
on that short story it's actually more
based on his novella which came out
which was written in 1931 called shadow
over Innsmouth yeah so this this movie
is pretty much a little more than half
of the story is shadow over Innsmouth
and there's like a little bit of Dagon
in there and then there's some kind of
other stuff that's duly important put in
there himself but it is a very the whole
atmosphere of it and it should be noted
too that even though re-animator and
from beyond i would class those as
horror comedies thereof campy they're
kind of over the top this one not so
much this one doesn't have a lot of
humor in it but in a way I think that
serves the story better it's very the
whole atmosphere of it is very real dark
it's very dark and wet yes and always
raining really cool because you know if
you've never read shadow over Innsmouth
it's basically about a guy who discovers
like a village of kind of half-fish
people mutants that worship a sea god
yeah called Dagon which is about what
this movie is about and the whole thing
like I said this is the this is the
dampest movie I've ever seen like it's
all it's always blueish gray and green
everything is moldy and dripping half
the time people aren't in about a half a
foot of water or yeah you can just you
feel clammy when you're watching it and
I think that's a really cool aspect of
the media it kind of puts you in the
middle oh yeah there's a lot of
illogical horror along with some kind of
like weird gore is almost on the level
of maybe like a house of a thousand
corpses in certain areas it is super
gory yeah parts it involves this
religious cult that worships the deep
ones yeah you know then the deep ones
arising you know what weird a god it's
awesome yeah awesome I like the foot
yeah I really really like the way and
like I said I'm really disappointed that
I didn't see it back at the time but
it's like you know watching it just a
few days ago I watched it on to B dot TV
I'm like guy how did I miss this one
this is it awesome I want to get this
one on blu-ray
yeah you should it seems like from what
I've read most horror sites that have
reviewed the movie I've given it
positive reviews and it's like you know
why doesn't this have more of love you
know that's really good it Stewart it's
a cult Snape er yeah it really is
on kind of more mainstream sites has
about a 70% you know positive rating
yeah which I'm always so skeptical but I
and this doesn't happen to me a lot I
don't see a lot of horror movies either
new ones or old ones that I missed that
I'm just like man I love this movie but
this one it really kind of hit the right
notes with me I just liked the whole
atmosphere of it I liked the weirdness
of it I liked them the characters like
going to this fishing village it's
called imboca
in the movie but that's like the Spanish
equivalent of ends mouth
yeah and them going there just like all
these weird people kind of shuffling
around with and they don't blink and
they're all yeah they're all slowly
transforming into aquatic creatures yeah
and it's like all that kind of thing and
it's just and there's really I mean the
story is fairly simple I mean the you
know the the characters the two main
characters who are named Paul and his
girlfriend Barbara they're kind of like
on vacation on this yacht they're kind
of he seems like he's some kind of
hotshot he just made a lot of money on
the stock market and they're kind of
vacationing off the court off the coast
of this Spanish village there's a storm
you know they have a problem and they
have to go to this village to get some
help for them and their two other
friends that we're still on the boat and
then pretty much the whole middle part
of the movie is Paul being sort of
pursued by these weird people in this
village and trying to get reunited with
his girlfriend who he doesn't know you
know where she's gone and kind of
running into this homeless guy who kind
of tells the whole story of the year and
everything be careful don't spoil too
much no I'm not gonna I'm just say
that's just the whole that's just the
loose what really struck me about this
movies you could tell that it was
crafted with love that whoever made this
movie and the people that worked on this
movie really were really had a love for
Lovecraftian horror yeah it's pretty
much done right well like I said and
they suffered for this movie I mean
they're they're wet constantly imagine
the imagine that I was thinking that
like when when it'll actually hold yeah
when we were watching it I was like this
movie I'm like it's awesome but for the
actors it must have been a miserable and
cold the whole time and in Boca I mean
every building is rundown and wet and
moldy and rusty and everything the
paint's peeling and it looks very
traditional old Spanish yeah the
spanish-colonial looking stuff it's
really cool yeah everything is just like
gross it even rowdy even the old cars
yeah cars from other eras are in there
it's just a the the ambience is really
good yeah and it takes it takes it to
another level over r-e animator and from
be even though I love those yeah like I
said you know it's not really a comedy
there's not much Nomar in it at all the
tone is more Lovecraftian oh yeah and
the other ones it definitely is and like
we were saying before it's mostly
practical effects yeah you know you get
to see there's one particular sequence
near the end should I say no don't ruin
nothing that is super super gross and
it's like filmed in like loving detail
yeah and it's done with practical
effects some of the CGI effects like I
said a little bit but it was 2001 so you
know they're good for the time this is
actually a lot of the underwater shots
like his dreams about mermaid and
everything like that are really
beautiful like it's really it's pretty
frightening this one that's a very
creepy in Atmos every
about it is creepy all the people in the
village are creepy it's a must-see for
children don't really do that you guys
unless you have like you know pretty
cool yeah the kids about ten you know
he's hardcore he watches yeah cuz like I
said it is pretty movie should scare the
[ __ ] out I loved being scared when I was
kid I did too actually and I was like
super Endora I surprised him back I said
I think kids might be immune to imagery
now they started watching horror movies
probably when I was about seven or eight
years old and they bothered me but I
liked that yeah you know what I mean
like I like those it was always so scary
but I was just like but that's awesome
that one I kind of watched another one
but like you said nowadays I think kids
are so elated that they just be like
whatever another thing that really
stands out and this movie to me is the
the old guy who is the last human
inhabitant of Boca yeah this is drunk
yeah you can barely understand him he's
got a really thick Spanish accent he
passed away shortly after this movie was
made yeah actually he I think he really
did look like he put a lot of liquor
down yes he did he really did he looked
like his role yeah he looked like they
was the real that that was the real deal
but too bad he did a great job in that
role yeah you can't understand
everything he says his ambience the you
know his presence is very effective in
this movie I bought I bought that
character and another thing I love about
this movie is the priestess Lucia yeah
yeah pretty girl she is a beautiful like
a supernaturally yeah beautiful girl
like kind of strange-looking but that it
really goes with the role
yeah just goth in her DNA and the outfit
that she wears it then like the outfit
she wears to there I still want to
cosplay that [ __ ] yeah she was very much
kind of a Morticia Addams kind of
character really yeah look you know
Morticia was mostly Spanish too you know
yeah that's right I think they kind of
like put a lot of Morticia in that they
do kind of and like I said she I mean I
believe she's actually quite famous in
Spain she went on to be a like on a
really famous TV show and stuff like
that but um this was really the only
thing I think I've ever seen her in but
yeah she was really good in this
and I wanted to mention something too
because I was reading I read the shadow
over Innsmouth that I read dig on a very
long time ago and something that I found
interesting and maybe it's just me I was
reading something that actually Robert
price who has been in our show before
talking about Jesus mythology but he's
also a Lovecraft HP Lovecraft expert and
he was saying that he thought that Dagon
and the shadow of her ends mouth was
actually inspired by a short story that
I am very familiar with which is called
fish head by Urban s Cobb and I know
that because it's in this book and I
still have it it's over there on the
bookshelf somewhere it was in this if
you guys remember like I said old people
like me
these Alfred Hitchcock anthologies of
old horror stories and this one was from
the mid-60s I want to say my grandfather
gave it to me when I was little it was
called stories that scared even me and
it had that story in it called fish head
and it's actually about a guy I think
it's set on the Mississippi River and
it's kind of about this weird guy that's
you know he works on a plantation or
something like that but like his mom was
a fish where I can't even remember but
he was like a half fish person for us so
the speculation is that Lovecraft may
have read this story and sort of used
that as a jumping-off place now it's
also said to that one he apparently
really really hated fish in general
which is why a lot of his monsters are
sea based also it's speculated that he
wrote shadow Varennes mouth all of this
stuff about like inbred fish mutant you
know or hybrid fish meet human people
because of his hatred for racial mixing
okay which yeah right because he was you
know quote-unquote disgusted by races
reproducing between each other so it was
actually kind of a lot of stuff in
Lovecraft anyway left after all he talks
about race yeah he was very he was very
into it that was just a man of this time
yes so I have so I have seen that that's
probably where he got the idea of this
one thing hybrid thing another thing
that really got me about this movie
though was how the the last inhabitant
of Boca how he explains how the cult of
Dagon
Wow yes he was old enough to remember
yeah as a child how the cult took over
yeah and he tells the story and they
reenact the story it's pretty cool do
you like him right right he explains how
Dagon
the cult of Dagon supplanted
Christianity yeah
Catholicism something right you know
Jesus didn't bring anything yeah it's
like hey God brought gold right fish
from the sea yeah and then they show how
that's just sounded like box fish from
the sea yeah but yeah that was uh that
was kind of a cool aspect of it too like
I said the hope mostly the middle of the
movie is pretty much one long chase
sequence but it is kind of intercut with
these kind of flashbacks of the main
character Paul finding out what happened
in this village and yet it is kind of
funny the way they're like well hey you
know we are all Catholics a long time
ago right but then the village was going
broke you know we won't know that you
get any fish and also Jesus didn't bring
fish Jesus didn't do [ __ ] right yeah you
know so then along and Dagon said figure
out where's all the gold and here's all
the you know they show that all you have
to do is yeah so you can return to the
sea right yeah and you know and it has a
little bit of a twist ending I guess I'm
not gonna give that away but I don't
know if it's the same as the story as
the end of the story shadow over
Innsmouth like I said I think it might
be a little different but I could be
wrong about that I haven't read it for a
long time I actually have an above Earth
err I should have read it before I think
the name of that video game I played on
the old xbox was called shadow over
Innsmouth it's pretty nice because you
kept telling me that you had your old
xbox that you had a video game and if
anybody out there knows like please put
it in the comments or the name because
it's driving him crazy trying to
remember it was awesome but yeah he said
it was a very similar vibe to this movie
so I said well maybe it was like based I
think a lot of a shadow raised me
because like I said that that story is
very similar to this movie you know it's
a it's a first-person adventure yeah it
wasn't a lot of fighting in it and if
you looked at a monster too long you
start flashing out and flickering out
and getting weak you couldn't look at
anything too long yeah because that's a
tn monster who drive you crazy dude you
got a 14 you got too scared it killed
you if you looked at it too long it's
really neat but I have Xbox one now and
I was looking for a Lovecraft game to
buy for that
nothing just Tesla versus Lovecraft
that's it which is cool but it's just
like an action I want a real
Lovecraftian horror adventure game for
Xbox wanted you know but then we can't
really pick one cuz like see I'm not you
know you have your Xbox one you play a
lot of video games on it I'm not I used
to play video games a lot back in the
day and then I just kind of got out of
it because I don't have a lot of time
but if I'm gonna play a video game I
would rather play something like I said
I want something like fallout because I
love fallout but I love but a love craft
version of fall where you can just kind
of like dick around and you're kind of
on your own timeline and you can go futz
around over here futz around over there
and you have different missions and
stuff yeah so I think I don't know if
there is one because I'm not really you
know they're working on something called
Call of Cthulhu but I don't know it I
think it might just be for PC I am it's
not available for Xbox one I yeah I mean
we yeah we threw all your all your game
wanted to buy one there's no more than
nobody out there yes so if somebody out
there is like making one that's no
because I would totally play that [ __ ]
yeah as I lie I think that would be
there's a lot of you know there's a lot
of board games or card games cuz I think
that there was one like that was called
Call of Cthulhu or something like that
it was like a card game sort of like
Magic the Gathering or something of that
nature but I don't know if they ever
made a video game version of it but I
would play the [ __ ] out of a video game
version of like a wrap based around like
a Dagon cult where you have set in a
creepy old village that was all wet and
everything like that that would be
[ __ ] red I don't know why somebody
doesn't make that yeah but yeah so this
movie like I said it really seems to
have flown under the radar I had heard
of it but I had never seen it and now
I'm kind of mad that I didn't see it
back when it came out doesn't get the
love it should go coach go check it out
because it's really really good and
obviously
really surprised I wasn't expecting it I
mean it was Stuart Gordon so I was
expecting it to be decent yeah but I was
better than these yeah when we watched I
was like wow that was fantastic
yeah really really good movie like I
said not funny so don't go into it
expecting another reanimate er because
it's it's different
bring your children children see this
[ __ ] tom tom says okay as long as the
kids are but also there might be titties
I think there's there's some nude scenes
at the end right with the girlfriend
yeah yeah I guess so
yeah is that a bad thing no I'm just
saying I'm just saying that yeah in the
in the interest of full disclosure if
you've got your kids to watch it yeah I
would go have your kids watch it was I
just get this [ __ ] I would not have
makes your childhood better well yeah
because like I said you know I I started
watching horror movies when they grow up
strong when I was little and I turned
that alright yeah yeah
they traumatised me when I was a kid but
I but I liked them right at 30 that
[ __ ] me up forever Maslov hasn't
window do you know what scared me
looking at the window at night yeah do
you know what scared the [ __ ] out of me
for some reason I think I was 9 yeah My
Bloody Valentine of all things yeah that
one didn't bother me to us
it's weird I don't know what like I see
it now and I don't know why it bothered
me but you know what bothered me the
most that scene where they opened the
candy box and there's like a human
hearted there I was like oh no no that
another one another one that bought
another one that kind of freaked me out
was the prototype for predator 1 it was
called without warning oh I remember
that yeah that one tripped me out a lot
of people say that remembered from there
and then a lot of people don't realize
that you know without warning was the
inspiration for predator it's a better
executed without warning yeah I think
I've heard that mentioned as what I
don't think I saw that back in the day
but for some reason there's probably not
even on blu-ray or DVD I do that one it
is
it's it's not one that's wrong nobody
knows it yeah yeah we're hunting people
but it was hunting teenagers who the
hell was the hunter teenager yeah who
the hell wants those and that so a bunch
of soldiers rewrote that yeah and made
the script for predator and then slip
that through teenagers had to be victims
and rise because they're like hey we can
show perky teenage Serenity's some ex
infantry guys saw that movie they said
[ __ ] that aliens would hot infantryman
and then rewrote the story both losers
that's right and they wanted a challenge
that's how that kids like why would you
just go to a go to a planet and like hot
teenagers wanna kill his head like that
yeah
smoking pot pot yeah easy yeah so if you
want to see Dagon if you have not seen
it like I said very underrated it is on
to be TV as of this recording at the end
of April so you're watching it for free
so it's not like making any money off
you get your cheap ass down let us know
what you thought about it yeah and
that'll do it for this latest movie
review of Stuart Gordon's 2001 Dagon
remember if you liked the show to like
share subscribe and share on all your
social media and if you'd like to
financially support the show you can go
to our patreon page which is patreon.com
slash 13 o'clock podcast or you can go
to our blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account where you
can give a one-time donation if you so
desire also remember to check out our
regular episodes which come out every
Tuesday and our movie reviews which come
out every Friday and until next time bye